نرحب بضيفينا اذا معنا من القدس مراسله
التي انجزت هذا الوثائقيه المؤثر والذي
شاهدناه ومعنا ايضا في الاستوديو الدكتور
ختار ابو دياب استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه باريس اهلا بكما اذن هذه الصور
المؤثره وهذا التقرير المؤثر الذي اعدته
للعربيه زميلتنا مفيده برهومي بدايه
لنصل الحوار حول هذا العمل المؤثر
جواندولين اهلا بك كيف جاءتك فكره
الالتفات الى هؤلاء المدنيين الذين تغيرت
حياتهم اين وجدتيهم وهل يعرفون بانهم
اصبحوا ابطالا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للانصار هذا جاءني من
مهمه اخرى فكانت مدينه كرتون تحت السيطره
القوات الروسيه اشخاص التقيت بهم سابقا
والذين كانوا يعملون في هذه المنطقه لقد
تم الحديث كثيرا عن انشطتهم وتم الحديث عن
مقاومتهم ولم يكن من الممكن انذاك ان نقوم
بشانهم بانهم كانوا يعملوا
منذ هذه التجربه فكانتها تنسيق ولم يكن
انذاك من الممكن ان نفعل ذلك ثم هناك
تحقيق سنه في نوفمبر الماضي وانا ذاك اصبح
من الممكن بالافاعي ان نكون ان نقوم
بروبوتاج اشخاص كانوا يريدون الحديث وان
يقدموا مشاهدات بالنسبه لما فعلوه وما فع
في مجال المقاومه والفكره هو ان اعطيهم
الكلمه وان يحكوا قصصهم كان ذلك مهم
بالنسبه لهم لان منطقتهم قد تم السيطره
عليها في الايام الاولى وكانت هذه رغبه من
هؤلاء الاشخاص اي ان يقولوا بان خرسون لم
يكن الامر يتعلق بتعاونين ولا لان روسيا
قد ضمت المنطقه سيقبلون ذلك كانت هناك
رغبه بان يدلوا بذلك وان يقول ذلك
بوضوح كانت هناك رغبه ليحكوا قصصهم ولقد
راينا بوضوح بعض هذه القصص وهذه النظرات
لدى شخصيات سواء في بدايه هذا الوثائق او
في النهايه مثلا عندما تحدث عازف الموسيقى
عن حياته قبل هذه الحرب فهل حدثوك عن
توقعاتهم لحياتهم ما بعد الحرب هل يتوقعون
ان يعودوا الى حياه طبيعيه
نعم بطبيعه الحال الجميع يامل بان يعود
الى حياه عاديه وان تتوقف هذه الحرب في
اقرب وقت ممكن فان المدنيون المدنيين
وكذلك الجنود يقولون ذلك هم يعيشون في
ولا يرون نهايه هذه الحرب فكان هناك جندي
الذي قال لي بانني لا اتوقع اي شيء فلقد
اخطات انا كنت بان هذه الحرب لن تحصلوا
انها ستكون قصيره للغايه هؤلاء الاشخاص لا
يمكنهم ان يتوقعوا ما سيجري فنحن نرى ذلك
في فهم يعيشون في مناطق التي هي مناطق
تقصى فكل يوم
وبالاتاليف الجميع يعيش داخل هذه الحرب
وهذا حياتهم اليوميه والجنود يواصلون
عملياتهم وراء
خطوطي العدو
ابقي معنا غواندو لينسا نذهب الى
ضيفنا خطر الدكتور خطر ابو دياب لنتوقف
عندما شاهدناهما ساعود اليك بسؤال اخر
دكتور خطار ما شاهدناه اذا في هذا
الوثائقي لاسيما هؤلاء الاشخاص العاديين
نساء رجال
مسنين كلهم
يذهبون الى هذه المقاومه ويخاطرون بحياتهم
هل ما هي الرمزيه وراء هذا هل هذا ما يجعل
من هذه المعركه معركه دفاع عن النفس
بنهايه المطاف يعني هذه الوثيقه من مدينه
كانت من اولى المدن التي اسقطها الجانب
الروسي ونحن في الذكرى الاولى الان لهذا
الغزو الروسي الاوكرانيا
موثيقه مهمه جدا لان الفكره الروسيه
اراضي روسيه تاريخيه وان بوتين اعلى
نظامها اعلى نظام خرسون التي ليست كلها
تحت سيطرته كما راينا وضم ذا بروجيا
ولوجانسيك زائد شبه جزيره القرم ما نراه
الان نعم هناك بعض المتعاونين في خرسون مع
ان الكثير من الناس هناك من اصول الروسيه
لكن يتضح لنا ايضا وبعمق ان اراده الشعب
الاوكراني في مكان اخر واننا امام صراع
وجودي يعني كما تقول سوريا روسيا انها في
صراع وجود اوكرانيا هي ايضا في صراع وجودي
ولهذا لاحظنا هنا كل اشكال المقاومه مدنيه
عسكريه وبالتالي المقاومه مكفوله من طرف
الامم المتحده اذا تعرضت ارض ما الى
الاحتلال راينا بان هناك يعني مخاطره
بالذات وبالنفس دكتور خطار هل الا يحيل
يحيلنا هذا الى حكايات مقاومه مثلا
المقاومه الفرنسيه ضد النازيه والمقاومه
في مقاومات اخرى مثلا الحكايه المقاومه ضد
الاحتلال نعم هذا هذا الحكايه المقاومه ضد
الاحتلال نتذكرها الان خاصه حكايه
المقاومه الفرنسيه ضد النازيه
ولكن الاهم هنا نلاحظ هذا التمزق الانساني
هذا الشعور الصعب جدا للانسان كيف ان هذا
الشخص الذي كان يتمنى ان يقاوم عندما كان
مراهقا في 2014 الان يندم على انخراطه في
هذه الحرب بينما نرى الرجل العجوز الذي
يقود احدى خلايا المقاومه مصمما على
الاستمرار هذا تناقض مهم جدا وهدد دليل
على ان حب الحياه اهم بالنسبه للناس من حب
الموت وكل هذا يعني لعنه الحرب الحرب بشعه
ولم نكن نتصور ان نعود الى زمن الحرب الى
هذه الحرب العليه الوتيره مع هذا الكم من
الخسائر البشريه الفادحه اذا نحن في عوده
الى الوراء القانون الدولي لا يحترم ومن
هنا التضامن العالم اوكرانيا نجده ولكن مع
الاسف بعد سنه لا نجد حتى اللحظه مخرجا من
هذه الحرب سنعود الى المقالات الجيو
استراتيجيه ان صح التعبير لهذا لهذه الحرب
حتى نفتح هذا النقاش ولكن قبل ذلك اعود
اليك جواندو راينا معا هذه
يعني الصور الصعبه جدا
برفقه هذه الكتيبه كتيبه براتسفو وقد فقد
احدهم حياته وجرح اخرون
وقد راينا معا هذه الصور المخيفه لهذه
المعارك الحيه فكيف استطعتم نقل هذه الصور
وكيف خاطرتم بارواحكم في هذه في هذه
المعركه اذا في هذه
الجبهه الاماميه
هل بامكانك ان تعيدي السؤال لو سمحتي
راينا معا
راينا معا هذه الصور الصعبه جدا للمعارك
في هذه العمليه التي نفذتها كتيبه براتسفو
على الجانب الاخر من النهر وراينا كيف فقد
احد الجنود حياته او احد المتطوعين حياته
بالاضافه الى جرح اخرين وراينا كل هذه كل
هذا القصف وكل هذه النيران كيف استطعتم
تصوير هذه المشاهد وكيف استطعتم الاحتماء
وسط هذه النيران
هذه العمليه كانت تم اعدادها بوقت مسبق
كان هناك
تمارينات ولقد شاركت ان شخصيا في هذه
التمانات
وكان هناك مجموعات متعدده كانت هناك
مجموعه التي كانت تعمل على اساس الطائرات
المسيره التي كانت تحلق على النهر
ومن الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانا كنت مع هذه
المجموعه ونرى ذلك في الصور
وهذه اذا كان كنا ايضا على
القوارب
وكان هناك ايضا
كنت انا شخصيا مع المجموعه التي كانت تقدم
الدعم حيث كانت هناك قوات اوكرانيه التي
تتحكم في الوضع
ما الذي علق قبل ان نختم معك
ما الذي علق بذهنك من خلال متابعه هؤلاء
الاشخاص
في الواقع انا اعتقد باننا عندما نصور
ونكون
محظوظين ان ندخل في ايطاليا عمليه من هذا
القبيل ليس هذا الامر نفعله كل يوم انا
بالنسبه لي ركزت بالفعل حتى افهم ما يحصل
كانت الامور معقده للغايه فانني
ارى الصور كنت ارى صور من الطائرات
المسيره لكن ما حاولت ان افعله وان نفهم
ما يحصل واين يوجد الجنود ومن هم
الموجودون في الضفه الاخرى
نفكر في الكثير لكن نركز بالفعل على على
فهم ما يجري امامنا وحتى نصور ما هو مهم
بالنسبه لنا
شكرا لك
جندولين زميلتنا
على هذه
على هذا الوثائقي في العمق وعلى هذه توثيق
لهذه المشاهد
النادره من هذه الحرب التي لا نراها في
الاخبار
ننتقل اليك دكتور خطار ابو دياب
لنفتح هذا النقاش حول الوضع في اوكرانيا
بعد اذن عام من الحرب بدايه ما اهميه
التوثيق لهذه الحرب التي صور يعني الكثير
بمقارنه مع حروب اخرى بثقت العديد من
مشاهدها كيف يمكن ان يساهم هذا في العداله
الدوليه بعد الحرب انسح التعبير
هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا هي حرب قرن التاسع
عشر وقرن عشرين وقرن الحادي وعشرين حرب
هجينه
ولم نكن نتصور كما قلت نعود اليها ليس
فيها فقط الدبابه فيها المسيره هذا شيء
جديد وفيها الجند العادي وعدنا ايضا
للخنادق في بخموت او للعمليات على ضفاف
الانهر كما راينا في خرسون ولكن الاهم ان
حرب المعلومه تبقى حرب المعلومه وهذا
العنصر الجديد في التوثيق مهم جدا
هناك الان شفافيه في الحروب اكثر من
الماضي لان هناك
اقمار الصناعيه تصور المعلومه تصل لا يمكن
ان تكون مخفيه لكن هذا وثائقي عن موقف
اهالي خرسون عن موقف هذه المنطقه عن اهميه
المقاومه عن اهميه
يعني هذا الصراع كما قلت هو صراع نوع من
التمزيق لان الجانب الروسي ايضا يعتبر ان
خرسون مدينته ولو كانوا اقليه جدا في
خرسون هذا الصراع الوجود صعب جدا ولذلك في
هذا الموضوع هكذا عمل خاصه اذا ثبتت مسائل
التعذيب وغيرها يمكن نعم ان تشكل وثائق
لمحاكمات او لاذانات مستقبليه كما راينا
ايضا بان هذه الحرب قد تكون حرب دعائيه
ايضا مثل ما هي الحال في جميع الحروب لكن
فلنعد الى الشق الجيو سياسي تفضلت دكتور
خطاب بالحديث عن يعني تازم او يعني مروحه
الازمه الى مكانها الرئيس بوتين قالها قبل
ايام في خطاب امام الكرملين بان روسيا لن
تستطيع ان تهزم بالمقابل اوكرانيا ما زالت
مستعده او ما زالت مصره على استرداد
اراضيها التي ضمتها روسيا واحتلتها
فبالتالي في ظل هذه المعادله
الصعبه الى اين يمكن ان تذهب الامور هل
هناك معركه مثلا هل هناك حل رابح رابح
ممكن ان يخرج عن هذا الانسداد حتى الان
كله خاسر خسر ونحن امام منطقين متناقضين
للتاريخ للجغرافيا وللحرب
والجانب الروسي نعم يقول انه لا يمكن ان
يهزم ومن الصعب جدا على الدب الروسي عندما
يتحرك ان يعود الى مكانه هذا عبر التاريخ
لكن لم يقرا التاريخ جيدا دوما الروسي
انتصر على نابليون داخل
اراديه وانتصر على هتلر داخل اراضيه
وعندما خرج خارج اراضيه حرب القرب مثلا او
اماكن اخرى لم يكن موفقا افغانستان في
مرحله الحديثه ولذلك ربما تم جره الى
افغانستان جديده لكن ذهب بملا ارادته
الاهم ان الجانب الاوكراني ايضا متعنت
ويقول انه يريد النصر والسيد يصل ليقول
انه يريد ان يسمح في مياه القرم هذا الصيف
والمساله اذا هي من ينزل عن شجره اولا لا
يبدو ان هناك من سينزل بالرغم من كل
الكلام على ما يبدو هذه المرحله على الاقل
من الان الى منتصف هذا العام مرحله معارك
ربما هجوم رو الواسعه في الربيع وهجوم
اوكرانيا مضاد سنرى بعد ذلك ان كان سيحصل
نقطه توازن وعند ذلك يمكن ان يصبح التفاوض
ممكننا لكن حتى اللحظه بالرغم من كل ما
يقال التعنت سيد الموقف
ونتيجه هذه المجابهه العالميه لان
المجابهه ليست فقط اوكرانيه الروسيه هي
مجابهه عالميه اوكرانيا لم تكن لتصمد لولا
الولايات المتحده واوروبا وراءها وكل
الغرب وروسيا ايضا بالرغم من كل شيء لولا
العمق الاقتصادي على الاقل الصيني والهندي
لم تكن لتصمد ولذلك المساله الان هي صراع
حاد صراع شاق
كلمه التسويه او كلمه السلام يمكن ان تكون
ولكن على المدى المتوسط وليس الان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في سؤال اخير قال بانه
سيترشح لولايه رئاسيه اخرى هل هذا المعطى
قد يغير الحرب
الرئيس بايدن عندما اتى اصلا الى كييف
واتى الى كيف بتقدير بترتيب مع الروس وليس
من دون علم الروس اتى من اجل ان يحسن
مواقعه ايضا لانه كل سياسه خارجيه متصله
بالسياسه الداخليه بالرغم من سنه المتقدم
السيد بايدن اثبت قدره على القياده لصالح
الولايات المتحده هل هذا لصالح اوكرانيا
او لصالح اوروبا هذه مساله اخرى هل هذا
لصالح العالم هذه مساله اخرى لكن نعم
السيد بايدن يستخدم الرافعه الاوكرانيه من
اجل تحسين حدود الديمقراطيين في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه سؤال استفهام
كبير حول حظوظه فعلا خاصه بانه لا يحظى
بدعم هذا الترشح لولايه ثانيه سنرى دكتور
خطار كيف الى ما ستؤول اليه المبادره
الصينيه في ظل هذه اللعبه الدوليه اشكرك
جزيلا دكتور خطار ابو دياب استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه باريس اش ايضا مراسله
التي انجزت لنا هذا العمل الوثائقي الهام
شكرا لكم انتم ايضا اعزائي المشاهدين الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]